so today I'd like to go over three
topics first our journey and decision
making process of kind of how we ended
up with web components and polymer
second an overview of the design system
and component library we've created over
last two years and last some highlights
of how we've been applying this design
system and how it's been a huge win for
EA and our players so let's start with
the story of how we landed with web
components so we need to go back about
two and a half years so basically a
decade in front-end world - February
2015 when we really started our journey
with web components and polymer years
approach to web was very different back
then we embodied Conway's law to the
fullest in how we delivered our
disjointed web ecosystem and for the
most part we designed and developed EA's
web more like an internal agency one
project one site at a time
this siloed and disjointed web was
really a sad place for our players and
equally a sad place for our designers
and developers - we were spending 80% of
our time on commodity web such as
navigation footers news articles media
galleries video player you know pre or
an by page leaving only a fraction of
our time to innovate excite and engage
our players with custom game specific
experiences so naturally in the world we
want to deliver we would flip this
allocation of time and focus around and
spend the majority of our time on the
fun engaging stuff instead so we started
really thinking and talking about okay
how do we get from this 8020 bad to this
8020 good and voila the network design
system project was born project name
aside this was really about applying
well-known concepts of a design system
at pattern library or a UI framework to
how we did web
the idea was that by having all of our
team members from product managers to
designers to developers to QA embracing
the complexity of the web with a
component based approach we could drive
efficiency and make our commodity core
web features turnkey but before we
started to hit the keyboard we took an
introspective look at ourselves what
other requirements needs once did we
have beyond those of a standard
component based design system what
special challenges did our context bring
to the table in the end our special
needs and wants for for the NDS distill
down to these four items number one to
facilitate deep theming capabilities to
work with any language and any framework
to support our microsite architecture
and to deliver user interface as a
service so let's look at these each and
more detail starting with facilitating
deep theming capabilities now ideally we
would have a solution that worked with
our entire spectrum of branding and
theming needs from one extreme being the
broad out-of-the-box kind of EA
corporate brand to the opposing extreme
being one that is heavily themed in a
very focused and specific manner for a
single game and in some cases meeting
the very stringent style guide
requirements and approvals from a
license or such as the cases with
Lucasfilm for the Star Wars franchise ok
number two let's talk about our desire
for this solution to be language and
framework agnostic recall this is early
2015 still and our group at that time
was the result of several internal team
mergers and reshuffles and as an outcome
we had a plethora of technologies
languages and paradigms in play from
frameworks and libraries such as Drupal
Symphony Grails spring angular drop
wizard and even jQuery 2 languages
including PHP Java and groovy
and content management systems such as
adobe experience manager vignette and
alfresco we had technology divergence so
unsure where we would end up with our
stack in the future we didn't want to
get locked in with any one particular
back end or front-end framework and
language this must work for the unknown
feature us as well as the rest of EA so
all right number three our micro site
architecture we had and to some extent
still have many discrete two web
applications that have their own
lifecycle teams budgets etc but are
assembled together to be perceived as
kind of one single cohesive player
experience what this means is that some
design elements such as global
navigation responsive UI big breakpoints
and grid login flow pre-order page need
to be centrally controlled and
consistent across all of our sites
whilst other design elements can be more
customized for each site okay last up
number four user interface as a service
so given this microsite architecture how
do we avoid projects that aren't being
actively developed from falling behind
and getting out of sync with the rest of
the EA ecosystem how do we keep all the
projects pointing to the latest version
of this design system with minimal
effort by delivering our UI conceptually
as a live service we hope to address
these issues and really embody the
mindset of leave no site behind okay so
given our goals to build this component
based network design system coupled with
our four special needs
where do we start I mean what's the
approach the architecture the system's
the tech the tools I mean there's a lot
of questions so just like the purple
pattern states and like any developer
should be I am lazy there's so much out
there and there's so many people to
learn and leverage from
so we begun reading listening
experimenting with and consuming
anything and everything we could
possibly get our eyeballs ears and hands
on in regards to the topic of style
guides design systems and UI frameworks
serendipitously a new podcast from style
guides IO was out and posting fresh
episodes on this topic right around the
time of early 2015 what a bonus so I'd
like to talk about three particular
paradigms and systems that were quite
inspirational and key to our path to web
components bootstrap and sort of friends
Lonely Planet and the government of the
UK starting with the ever-popular
bootstrap and more generally UI
frameworks this that follow the same
approach so here's a simplified example
of what integration of a bootstrap like
component library might look like you
include a pre bundled CSS and JavaScript
file from some CDN location and off you
go using the components the system
provides seems easy seems awesome seems
good right so let's use this pagination
component as an example it's a good one
because it has some reasonably complex
UI different states some brains inside
and it really needs to interact with
other components in code to actually do
something that's meaningful so let's see
how we integrate this component we start
by going to the documentation for the
page nader find the sample HTML snippet
then we copy and paste this large chunk
of code into our application okay you
know it's obviously not good from a
reusability and upgradability standpoint
as we have essentially forked this chunk
of code and will now need to manually
merge those updates as they come along
additionally there's little to no
encapsulation all of the internal
structure and all the style are exposed
to me as an integrator I mean what
really is the public API is it is it all
of it so we're not done we still need to
hook up some behavior now to this pager
by means of Java Sea
and this is generally completed by
grabbing a reference to the root element
of the component and passing it to some
factory or constructor as shown here
okay so the bootstrap model shows us one
way to do it
let's move on to Lonely Planet and see
their approach much like us Lonely
Planet had a microsite Architecture
comprising many sites each with our own
stack and team around them that need to
work together to provide a single
cohesive user experience their initial
approach was to create a shared UI layer
following the bootstrap like model we
just explored and in this diagram taken
out of a talk by Ian feather of Lonely
Planet you can see the two core problems
around risk and reuse depicted the
shared layer has the most reuse but as
changes here can affect all the
applications that use it risk is high
when making modifications especially
without a clear API boundary do this
lock of API you really don't know what
people are doing with your component so
over time engineers naturally will shy
away from making changes and doing
things in the shared layer because
they're afraid of breaking stuff so the
shaved shared layer shrinks and
atrophies while the site specific layers
grow basically the anti vision of any
shared component UI system
so what Lonely Planet did with their
design system dubbed rizzo was move away
from the copy-paste approach by
encapsulating each component into a Ruby
on Rails helper that took two parameters
one being the name of the component and
the second parameter being the clean and
minimal set of data that that component
needed to render this is much much
better so by implementing this component
layer and API between the shared layer
and the specific sites they're able to
reduce or remove the risk of making
changes to those components as well as
really ease overall integration efforts
significantly so the Lonely Planet's
folks really plus one the bootstrap
model with their rizzo system
naturally this is my face after coming
across Rizzo so excited and essentially
ready to lock in and go with this
approach but not so fast
sometime after Rizzo had been humming
long in production
Ian feather put up a blog post titled
what we would change about Rizzo
first the solution was tied very tightly
to Ruby on Rails and ER B templates and
hence was not portable or usable by
applications that employed different
languages or frameworks he hypothesized
about using mustache templates or
similar to sort of mitigate that issue
second all of that CSS HTML Javascript
and Ruby that made up Rizzo was bundled
and integrated into each site via a ruby
gem so each update to Rizzo meant he had
to go through a dependency update build
test and release cycle to each of their
ten plus integrating sites
okay so Lonely Planet's Rizzo was an
excellent overall approach clean API
data-driven components but before move
on being Canadian all we figured it
would be a good idea to check in with
the Queen over at the government of the
UK inspired by the Lonely Planet
approached ed Soudan working with the
government of the UK really wanted to
resolve that issue of the effort and
cost of propagating those changes from
the component UI layer into those
integrating sites so building on the
core approach of Rizzo they out of the
concept of a template resolver whereas
all those ERP templates were moved out
of the gem and it to some shared network
location and then they're lazy loaded
from this location and cached locally
for a short period of time
this combined with pre bundling the CSS
and JavaScript on to that CD on location
allowed for it changes to be propagated
with minimal effort to all their apps as
you can see the WK folks really took the
already awesome Lonely Planet approach
and +1 did big-time with the addition of
that template resolver
now we got quite excited about this
approach it really felt like a viable
option for us to start heading down but
before we delve into deep we're back to
our four special needs
just to make sure and see how things
measure up so number one deep theming
capabilities now reminder this is still
early 2015 so CSS custom properties were
only available in about 10% of users
browsers okay so I'm not sure how we can
do this exactly you know I guess we can
figure something out perhaps each site
can build their own CSS override file
that just has the CSS rule sets that
need to be modified to the theme those
components okay but what happens when we
refactor some CSS or we introduce a new
component
I guess we'll need to rebuild those
override files okay well I mean we've
got some tools to build I've got a
process of documents and people to train
alright number two let's see working
with any language any framework well I
mean we could just use mustache
templates coupled with the same WK
template resolver approach that would do
the trick
we just need to build client libraries
now for every language that we need to
support okay so that's like PHP Java
JavaScript I mean that minimum and then
ideally we'd have first-class
integration into the front and back and
frameworks that we might use so let's
see that's at least four frameworks oh
boy now there's already a lot of open
questions plumbing and miscellaneous
pieces to worry about here already now
remember I am a lazy developer I don't
want to write and maintain code if I
don't have to I really wished that there
was just an off-the-shelf solution that
I could just grab read some Doc's gives
me everything I need and one nice
cohesive package okay so back to the
drawing board what else what else what
else I mean we have designs for all our
components now like we need to start
getting on some code like really soon so
I remember this this hipster tech that
was brewing for what feels like years
now
sounds cool on paper web components
and Google Palmer I think it was oh yeah
that's right I remember there was a talk
at Google i/o in 2013 oh yes now I
remember a fun looking toy terrible
performance due to some nasty invasive
dom polyfills basically chrome only I
mean like way too hipster for this job I
mean this is all of EA's web hinging on
this decision I need a solution that is
ready for production at a a scale like
today but wait what is this polymer 1.0
just released like now production-ready
web components really all right sounds
good on first glance backed by Google
focused around components and not
full-blown applications all right all
right chill out Alex back to our special
needs first and let's see how things
measure up so number one okay deep
theming capabilities well we get theming
right out of the box using CSS custom
properties and mix ins with a shim that
works everywhere cool we can theme these
components at runtime to no build step
necessary it's pretty awesome all right
number two working with any language any
framework well I mean it's really just
an HTML element at the end of the day
and almost standard Dom interface so
hypothetically anybody or anything that
can put an HTML tag into a document
should technically use our components
built with polymer oh and all the CSS
HTML and JavaScript is bundled up
together into an h2 my import for
client-side inclusion so no tie into any
specific back end or front end language
or framework needed awesome this is like
sounding really good all right number
three support our micro site
architecture well it seems that we can
control the API however we want on a per
component basis so that should work well
and last up user interface as a service
well it's just client-side integration
HTML imports seems like it has some of
the basic working pieces to make this
happen so yeah this is looking really
good
so my mind is blown at this point an
off-the-shelf solution that meets all of
our special needs and lots more tooling
Docs etc less code from my team to write
makes me very happy
and bonus is that most of the gnarly
parts of polymer are promised to be
native web platform primitives sometime
soon too
I mean a frameworks roadmap that states
that it wants to get smaller do less
over time and eventually may not even
need to exist I mean that's amazing
so with polymer this hipster web
components thing just became our top
contender so compared with the already
awesome approaches of Lonely Planet and
the government of the UK web components
in polymer 1.0 was like a plus 100 so in
September of 2015 we decided to
officially lock in with web components
and polymer as the core technology for
the network design system now let's fast
forward two years later down our journey
with web components polymer and the NDS
you know what did we end up building how
did our for special needs sort of hold
up in real life did web components and
polymer meet my mind-blown expectations
I'm pleased to say that we have
approximately 75 components that are
arranged into one of six component
families which are just logical
groupings of components based on their
purpose let's look at a few examples
starting with our most commonly used
component our call to action or button
component you know it's quite
polymorphic and it supports different
types for text text with icons images
and so on and this component also comes
with Google Analytics tracking
out-of-the-box ensuring that every
button on every site sends consistent
and meaningful data next up is our
pagination component something with
quite a bit more logic and state than a
button to me this paid reader really
showcases the power of web components
all that complex structure style and
behavior
are nicely encapsulated away behind this
minimal clean declarative and imperative
API in this example we just simply
listen to that page change event and do
what we need to do with the data we also
have some very high-level components
that are almost like encapsulated in
many applications all in their own this
newsletter signup has various states for
anonymous users authenticated user
already signed up as well as it provides
a multi-step flow complete with error
handling localization and integration
with a few external service api's
alright so now with that sample of
components in mind let's review our
special needs again and see how we've
applied web components and polymer to
bring these to fruition starting with
facilitating that broad spectrum of
brand specificity and fidelity that we
needed now we have about 300 CSS custom
properties that are set at the
system-wide level that are there to
mostly control color and typography we
love that even back in 2015 when CSS
custom properties were not widely
available the shim that came with
polymer 1.0 allowed us to use this
powerful tool to theme dynamically at
runtime with no build necessary in fact
we now control these primarily through
our content management system so a
designer and a product manager can spin
up a site and theme it without any
developers involved we also have many
CSS custom properties they've used as
internal design tokens and are really
there just to keep things dry from a
development standpoint but they should
not really ever be exposed or altered by
our integrators in any way and so you
know these are rules such as our
responsive grid gutter and column widths
so what we do is at a build time using
post CSS we substitute and compile in
the static values for these at these
design tokens making them essentially
immutable
and leaving only the FEMA bill CSS
custom properties exposed so this is our
tile or our card component and it's used
in most places where we have a list of
items to display such as a news article
videos characters or weapons and all
those CSS custom properties are great
for granular CSS level control using
HTML attributes as another way to
the--my control a component has deemed
to be very powerful
the example illustrates as well is the
type attribute on this tile that has two
possible values horizontal and vertical
using the host pseudo selector we can
have that single HTML attribute impact
the entire presentation of the component
fronting placement and size of the media
asset from origins and padding to
different layouts completely that mobile
versus desktop all by letting CSS and
the browser do all the hard work no
imperative JavaScript needed so just by
using those system-wide theme theme of
all CSS custom properties and the per
component HTML attributes we can deliver
all four of these tiles using the exact
same component all themed at runtime to
boot
okay number two let's talk about how the
need to be a language and framework
agnostic has gone here's a very
simplified view of our overall stack
today we have Abdo be experienced
manager as our CMS in the backend light
bends Play Framework as our middleware
and of course polymer in the front end
now we have taken the approach that when
we think about a component we think
about how it manifests across this
entire stack not just in the front end
ensuring that we can drag a drop a
component onto a page in the CMS pull
that component into the middleware and
serve out the custom element for polymer
to then render so for our stack each
component has first-class integration
top to bottom in this example of a
button
but this does not mean that integrators
must use our full stock to get the
benefit of the network design system as
each layer the stock is loosely coupled
and has clear API boundaries it's really
easy to just use that front-end polymer
component all on its own no gem no
template service client library just a
simple HTML import okay so number three
our micro site architecture so recall
that some components need to be
centrally controlled and consistent
whilst others can be more customizable
web components and polymer makes this
really easy as we get to control how
narrow or how broad the API is on a per
component basis components that we
really need to be nearly a hundred
percent consistent across all sites we
just simply severely restrict the API in
to that component and others that are
meant to be super flexible have all
sorts of knobs and switches in the form
of CSS custom properties HTML attributes
and view sub slot based composition so
our pre order by widget newsletter
signup footer Network navigation are all
examples of where we really keep that
API minimal okay last up number 4 user
interface as a service now we apply some
ver very very diligently being super
careful to keep the NDS backwards and
forwards compatible with a strong focus
on not bumping our major version number
for as long as possible
sticking to backwards compatible changes
resulting in minor version bumps only so
this mindset has worked really well as
we are currently at version 1.30 1.0 and
in practice we could update a site from
1.2 0 to 130 1.0 without any code
changes or issues currently we deploy a
pre-built version of the NDS to a CDN
location using a naming convention as
shown here so this gives a URL meaning
as to the version the artifact type
and the artifact that's being referenced
by supporting fuzzy version mask on the
major release version means that the
sites can ask for a 1 dot star a 1 dot X
and get back a 302 that actually
redirects them to the latest one dot X
release which as it is a tagged and
unchanging artifact is sent back with a
very aggressive caching policy so as you
can see our special needs have come to
fruition thanks to web components and
polymer now I'd like to briefly cover a
few more wins and show off some of our
sights so as mentioned we have 75
components in production they're now
powering about 30 sites in total and
that number is growing rapidly every day
on the left is a calm corporate site
using the out-of-the-box default theme
and on the right is a more heavily
styled titanfall 2 site but both using
the same and yes version and the same
HTML import and here are a couple more
with Mass Effect on the left and on the
right an upcoming new franchise from
Bioware anthem and we have gone from a
previous tedious and lengthy process to
bring up a site to now only taking about
one and a half weeks of content only
that means no development effort so
component type thinking is really just
how we operate across all functions now
we don't design and build pages anymore
we are always looking to decompose and
then compose with component based
building blocks and as a bonus to the
delight of our digital intelligence team
we have been very consistent and
complete Analects tracking across all of
our components allowing us to compare
apples to apples between different sites
and of course efficiency and economy of
scale we've reduced duplication we have
better engineering mobility between
projects and teams
and with a predictable proven and
streamlined system we have much much
lower project risk and a far more
dependable schedule so going back to
this original goal of living in a world
of making our commodity web turnkey low
effort and maintainable how have we done
I would say a resounding success thanks
to web components and polymer thank you
very much
[Applause]